stell dir vor du sitzt in einem flugzeug
und die bundeswehr schießt es einfach ab
[Musik]
stell dir vor der klimawandel macht sich
schon heute direkt vor seiner haustüre
bemerkbar ich habe angst dass mein
zuhause vom meer überflutet wird stell
dir vor du musst ein kind austragen dass
du gar nicht willst ich darf als ärztin
nicht sachlich und seriös über
schwangerschafts abbrüche informieren
stell dir vor du wirst in einer
ausbildung nicht so behandelt wie die
anderen ich durfte während meiner
juristinnen ausbildung nicht mit meiner
richterin sitzen sondern musste auf der
zuschauerbank platz nehmen was dann
wohin gehst du mit solchen problemen wir
erzählen dir heute von 16 menschen die
dir in einer solchen situation helfen
oder zumindest helfen können und
natürlich sagen wir auch wie die
geschichten ausgegangen sind
[Musik]
[Applaus]
vielleicht ist es ein thema dass hier
gerade einfach gar nicht mehr hören
könnt der klimawandel
information overload aber es gibt
menschen für die ist der klimawandel
wirklich richtig bedrohlich
lüthi recktenwald ist einer von ihnen
seine familie betreibt auf der kleinen
nordseeinsel langeoog ein hotel lücke
ist 20 und wohnt schon immer hier wenn
der klimawandel so weitergehen sollte
könnte das für ihn krasse folgen haben
das für uns bedeuten dass wir die insel
sage ich meinem ernstfall verlassen
müssen weil sie nicht mehr bewohnbar
wäre oder schon land unter
gegebenenfalls und dann natürlich den
dreh und angelpunkt unseres lebens
verschrieben und das wäre natürlich sehr
traurig für uns alle das möchte keiner
deshalb ist lücke vor gericht gezogen
am strand filme zeigen wie das meer die
insel schon heute bedroht
kraft und tiefe kannte ja ganz wohl
sagen
und diese karte entsteht sozusagen jedes
jahr neu oder wie es also es ist so dass
der bereich wo wir gerade stehen ja das
ehemalige spülfeld quasi ist also hier
wird dann übers jahr hinweg quasi der
ganze sand angespült bzw menschen
gemacht natürlich also halt von von dem
schiff im westen der insel wunder anhalt
große leitungen er verlegt wo der sand
hier angespült und von den baggern und
bulldozern und einem gerät verteilt so
zu sagen und das ist war sie als als
schutz masse vor der bühne hätten die
wir da im namen und sollte jedoch quasi
durchbruch in den passieren und sei es
was einen zins erinnerte gelangt dann
könnte es passieren dass diese wende
versalzen ist und habe keine vernünftige
trinkwasserversorgung das heißt es muss
um jeden preis vermieden werden dass das
meer hier über diese dummen gruber
strafzeit ja das kann man
in wie weit die kante eine direkte folge
des klimawandels ist ist schwer zu sagen
in jedem fall finden die auf spülungen
öfter statt und mehr sturmfluten und
ansteigender meeresspiegel würde die
insel noch mehr in gefahr bringen
und da kommen die 16 menschen ins spiel
die in einer solchen situation helfen
können nämlich die richterinnen und
richter des bundesverfassungsgerichts
die entscheiden über solche fälle und im
fall von lücke ist was passiert womit
niemand eigentlich wirklich gerechnet
hatte er bekam nämlich recht das
klimaschutzgesetz verstößt gegen das
grundgesetz sagte die höchsten deutschen
richterinnen und richter das gesetz
macht nämlich nur bis zum jahr 2030
konkrete vorgaben inwieweit
klimaschädliche emissionen gemindert
werden sollen was danach passiert darf
aber nicht offen bleiben so das
bundesverfassungsgericht
außerdem reichen aber die gesetzlichen
vorgaben bis zum jahr 2030 nicht aus das
zwei grad ziel zu erreichen so dass die
generation nach 2030 die hauptlast beim
klimawandel tragen müssten und das geht
nicht sagt das gericht denn dann würden
wir alle in unserem grundfreiheiten ganz
massiv eingeschränkt für mich persönlich
bedeutet
das natürlich ein erfolg und generell
bedeutet ist natürlich also erst mal
dass das auch einfach das grundgesetz
generationengerecht endlich ausgelegt
wurde dass man sagt okay wir haben ein
problem die klimakrise das muss gelöst
werden und es ist halt so dass man nicht
sagen kann ob die wir vertagen das
problem will vertrags bis dann auf
einmal sah ich mal meine und kommende
generationen dastehen ich sage mal im
ernstfall land unter ist oder wir auf
einmal gar nichts mehr dürfen das
bundesverfassungsgericht feiert in
diesem jahr sein 70 jähriges bestehen
und es ist ein ganz besonderes gericht
denn es steht gewissermaßen über allen
über der bundesregierung über der
bundeskanzlerin und sogar über den
bundespräsidenten denn die entscheidung
des gerichts gelten für alle ganz
verbindlich die erfahrung aus der
nazizeit mit der diktatur von adolf
hitler haben dazu geführt dass man diese
unabhängige gerichtliche kontrolle so
ins grundgesetz geschrieben hat das
bundesverfassungsgericht urteilt aber
längst nicht über alles es ist nicht die
letzte instanz in den gerichtsverfahren
sondern es überprüft ob alles im
einklang mit der verfassung also mit dem
grundgesetz steht um sich gegen den
staat zu wehren muss man deshalb in den
meisten fällen erst mal ganz normal vor
gericht ziehen zum beispiel vor das
verwaltungsgericht dann geht der fall
durch alle instanzen also zum
oberverwaltungsgericht und dann zum
bundesverwaltungsgericht
erst ganz am ende überprüft dann das
bundesverfassungsgericht in karlsruhe ob
ein verstoß gegen das grundgesetz
vorliegt daneben landen auch fälle in
karlsruhe bei denen es streitigkeiten im
staat gibt wenn sich zum beispiel eine
bundestagsfraktion und die
bundesregierung nicht einig werden wie
groß ist deine hoffnung dass das 15 oder
das zwei grad ziel überhaupt noch
erreicht wird ich denke noch ganz in
weiter ferne ist es noch nicht also es
ist noch erreichbar und wir müssen halt
jetzt handeln und wir müssen auch jetzt
gucken dass sich die kommende regierung
hinsetzt und pläne rausbringen die
auswirkung des klimawandels sind heute
schon sichtbar das krasse in der
entscheidung des verfassungsgerichts ist
aber dass man sich ab sofort auch eine
bessere zukunft einklagen kann also
rechte geltend machen kann die ersten
der zukunft relevant werden
jetzt mal ein kleines gedankenspiel
stellt euch vor ihr sitzt in einem
flugzeug und dieses flugzeug wird von
terroristen oder terroristen entführt
die drohen damit das flugzeug abstürzen
zu lassen zb in ein hochhaus wie am 11
september in new york oder in ein voll
besetztes fußballstadion in deutschland
gab es diesen fall zum glück noch nicht
aber man hat 2005 vorsorglich ein neues
gesetz dafür geschaffen danach dürfte
die bundeswehr ein solches entführtes
flugzeug abschießen der gedanke war man
opfer das leben der passagiere um am
boden das leben einer größeren zahl von
menschen zu retten das ist ganz schön
krass und das fanden auch zwei
bundesminister zwei ehemalige der fdp
die das gesetz für falsch hielten und
die höchsten richterinnen und richter
gaben ihnen recht und
satzung als objekte wenn er deren tötung
aus
mittel zur rettung anderer menschen
benutzt im klartext man darf nicht
menschenleben gegen menschenleben
aufwiegen das leben eines menschen ist
genauso viel wert wie das leben eines
anderen
jedes jahr gehen tausende von
verfassungsbeschwerden und klagen beim
bundesverfassungsgericht ein nur einen
ganz ganz kleiner teil davon hatte aber
erfolg in den letzten zehn jahren waren
das 1,88 prozent also wirklich wirklich
wenig
die richterinnen und richter die
diskutieren über jeden einzelnen fall
sehr ausführlich und beratend lange zeit
und deshalb dauert es oft monate oder
sogar jahre bis wirklich entschieden
wird
manchmal muss es aber auch ganz schnell
gehen so wie im oktober
1977 als die richterinnen und richter
über leben und tod entscheiden mussten
der arbeitgeberpräsident hanns martin
schleyer war von der raf entführt worden
und seine familie wollte die
bundesregierung dazu zwingen auf die
forderungen der terroristen und
terroristen einzugehen das
bundesverfassungsgericht beriet sich
eine ganze nacht hindurch und morgens um
55 wurde das urteil verkündet in dieser
sache wird
im namen des volkes
folgendes urteil verkündet der antrag
auf erlass einer einstweiligen anordnung
wird abgelehnt das gericht sagt also die
bundesregierung muss die forderungen der
familien nicht erfüllen die reaktion des
staates auf terrorismus dürfe für
täterinnen und täter nicht kalkulierbar
werden das war eine entscheidung die
einem todesurteil für hanns martin
schleyer gleichkam zwei tage später
wurde er von der raf erschossen
[Musik]
stell dir vor du hast ein kind in dir
dass du aber nicht austragen möchte ist
was machst du du gehst ins internet
recherchiert und du stehst auf die
homepage von einer ärztin die dort
schreibt dass die schwangerschafts
abbrüche in ihrer praxis anbietet auf
der homepage steht aber auch und achtung
darauf wird es jetzt gleich ankommen wie
sie das konkret macht dieser ärzten
steht am ende vor gericht und zwar als
straftäterin der vorwurf werbung für
schwangerschafts abbrüche
hier in gießen hat christina händel ihre
praxis in der sie schwangerschafts
abbrüche vornimmt sie wurde verurteilt
weil sie schlicht zu viele informationen
auf ihre website gestellt hat es ist
zwar rechtlich erlaubt mitzuteilen dass
man schwangerschaftsabbrüche vornimmt es
ist aber verboten öffentlich mitzuteilen
wie man das macht also zum beispiel mit
welchen methoden die rechtslage ist klar
mit der will sich christina helle aber
nicht abfinden
[Musik]
es ist ein bisschen das was ich
sie wurden jetzt zweimal verurteilt
haben sie hat vielen vielen jahren ich
sag mal ärger mit dem thema
schwangerschaftsabbruch warum nehmen sie
all das auf sich
weil ich das für die betroffenen mache
ich sehe dass jeden tag in meiner arbeit
was das bedeutet dass die gesetzeslage
so ist in deutschland wie sie ist und
merke dass damit menschen was gemacht
wird was gegen den artikel 1 unseres
grundgesetzes nämlich die würde des
menschen ist unantastbar massiv verstößt
und alles was man anderen antut hat man
auch mir getan ich halte es einfach
nicht aus ja und ich möchte was
verbessern
christina himmel steht für eine bewegung
von frauen die darum kämpfen über ihren
eigenen körper bestimmen zu können in
den sozialen medien hat das verfahren
riesige aufmerksamkeit bekommen und
tausende gingen auf die straße an dieser
stelle muss es auch gelten dass sich
betroffene sachlich und seriös
informieren kann das geht gar nicht
anders ich als ärztin meiner beruflichen
pflichten wie aufzuklären dass das in
deutschland nicht möglich sein darf nur
weil ich es hat ja gar keine konsequenz
ich verhindere damit keinen einzigen
abbruch aber ich mache den weg sehr eng
und es fallen immer wieder welche durchs
raster die finden den weg nicht die
finden die adressen ich sie lange im
ausland oder sie landen dann doch eben
bei den illegalen methoden oder sie
langen beim suizid das kriegen wir nicht
mit aber auch diese fälle gibt es in
deutschland
christina handel klagt sich bis vors
bundesverfassungsgericht
was sagen die richterinnen und richter
die entscheidung ist noch nicht gefallen
könnte aber jeden tag kommen ich hoffe
vom bundesverfassungsgericht dass unsere
ansicht dass der paragraph 219 mit dem
grundgesetz nicht vereinbar ist getragen
wird und das ist zu einer neuregelung
des informations verbotes kommen muss
und wie würde so eine neuregelung aus
ihrer sicht das aussehen das würde ich
der politik überlassen ich bin keine
politikerin und auch keine juristin ich
möchte nur dass wir ärzte frei und
sachlich und seriös informieren dürfen
auch zum thema schwangerschaftsabbruch
gerade beim stichwort politik gibt es
kritik am bundesverfassungsgericht
genauer gesagt an der besetzung also an
der auswahl der richterinnen und richter
zwar kommen die meisten aus der
wissenschaft oder aus der justiz aber es
gibt auch einige die früher politikerin
oder politiker waren zum beispiel peter
müller war früher ministerpräsident des
saarlandes ist heute richter am
bundesverfassungsgericht oder stefan hat
der amtierende präsident des
bundesverfassungsgerichts der war früher
bundestagsabgeordneter für die cdu und
damals hat er in einer rede zum thema
schwangerschaftsabbruch folgendes gesagt
wir wollen im abtreibungs bereich keine
werbung sondern wir wollen mut und hilfe
bei der entscheidung gegen
schwangerschafts abbrüche geben und
deshalb werden wir diese anträge
ablehnen herzlichen dank
jetzt liegt die entscheidung bei dem
gericht dessen präsident er ist und es
gibt dort zwei senate entscheidend wird
über diesen fall der zweite senat in dem
arbeit nicht mitglied ist deshalb wird
er in der entscheidung auch nichts
mitzureden haben und nicht nur wenn es
um den anfang des lebens geht ist das
bundesverfassungsgericht am start auch
mit fragen rund um das lebensende den
tod beschäftigt sich das gericht im
februar 2020 wurde über die
verfassungsbeschwerde von helmut
feldmann entschieden er leidet an einer
unheilbaren lungenkrankheit
helmut feldmann möchte gerne selbst
bestimmen wann und vor allem wie er
stirbt
würde des menschen auch dazu dass wenn
ein mensch
schwer krank ist und sein leben beenden
möchte wird die möglichkeit bekommt das
euro auf dem land illegal weh zu tun und
das gericht gab ihm recht jeder mensch
hat die freiheit sich selbst zu töten
sagt das gericht es gibt also ein recht
auf selbstbestimmtes sterben und ganz
wichtig man darf sich dabei auch von
organisationen helfen lassen selbst dann
wenn diese organisation damit geld
verdienen wenn die das also kommerziell
machen ein wirklich bahnbrechendes
urteil des gerichts und die politik hat
bis heute eigentlich nicht so richtig
einen weg gefunden wie sie damit umgehen
will das höchste deutsche gericht
genießt seit 70 jahren einen ziemlich
exzellenten ruf es verteidigt die
grundrechte von uns allen es weist den
start die politik in ihre schranken und
es klärt sehr viele komplexe fragen aber
es gibt natürlich auch kritik zum
beispiel dass sich das gericht zu sehr
in die politik einmischen also zu sehr
die rolle des gesetzgebers statt die des
gerichts einnehme
wolfgang schäuble etwa sagte 2009 über
das bundesverfassungsgericht wer gesetze
gestalten will sollte sich bemühen
mitglied des deutschen bundestages zu
werden
und norbert lammert war 2014 der
überzeugung dass das verfassungsgericht
zwar die einhaltung des rechts
kontrollieren müsse aber dabei sollte
sich auch das gericht immer wieder
vergewissern ob es die im selbst
gesetzten grenzen
seinerseits so ein held wie es dies von
anderen institutionen verlangt
zurzeit wird auch oft kritisiert dass
das bundesverfassungsgericht nahezu alle
corona maßnahmen ja durchgewunken hat
und sich mit den entscheidungen über die
wichtigsten punkte sehr viel zeit lässt
[Musik]
wie viel platz darf religion im staat
einnehmen diese frage stellen sich
richterinnen und richter seit es die
verfassung gibt darf im klassenzimmer
zum beispiel ein kreuz hängen wie sieht
es mit anderen religiösen symbolen aus
es mal le3 sie ist promovierte juristin
ihre ausbildung hat sie aber nicht ganz
beendet denn es gab ein problem sie
wollte während des referendariats sowie
ihre kolleginnen auch als staatsanwältin
verhandeln oder auf der richterbank
platz nehmen mit ihrem kopftuch denn sie
ist muslimin das wurde ja aber verboten
man sagte mir dass man übersehen hat
dass ich ein kopftuch trage und und in
diesem fall müsste man mich darauf
hinweisen dass ein paar tätigkeiten
während des referendariats verboten sind
aufgrund des kopftuches und ob ich das
immer noch machen will welche
tätigkeiten
das sind zum einen neben dem richter
oder der richterin zu sitzen
beweisaufnahmen durchzuführen
denn die staatsanwaltschaft zu vertreten
also sitzungsdienst zu machen und dann
fing das referendariat an eben in dem
wissen dass das ich eben bestimmte
tätigkeiten nicht
ausführen durfte und ich hab dann
beschwerde eingereicht ganz am ende
dieses juristischen verfahrens entschied
das bundesverfassungsgericht
und zwar gegen erstmal literacy
die bundesverfassungsrichterin und
richter entscheiden darüber wie weit
grundrechte reichen und wo sie
vielleicht auch ihre schranken finden
ständig wird abgewogen ein sehr
komplizierter prozess ist das
insbesondere dann wenn verschiedene
verfassungsrechte miteinander
kollidieren so auch in istres fall wo
auf ihrer seite unter anderem ihre
religions- und berufsfreiheit steht auf
der anderen seite aber die staatliche
neutralitätspflicht
und die freiheit anderer sich mit ihrer
religion nicht beschäftigen zu wollen
und diese abwägung ist immer eine frage
des einzelfalls wenn man sich jetzt die
argumentation des verfassungsgerichts
anschaut dann könnte man ja schon
vertreten dass die personen die vor
gericht stehen die eine unabhängige
richterin einen unabhängigen richter zum
beispiel erwarten und das ja auch zu
recht erwarten dass die
vielleicht das gefühl bekommen dass die
richterin nicht unabhängig ist wenn sie
ein kopftuch trägt was hast du zu diesem
argument es ist fast eine beleidigung
wenn man bedenkt dass man mir
unterstellt auf pump eines kopftuchs bin
ich in meiner entscheidungsfindung nicht
neutral
aufgrund eines äußeren merkmals auf
meine innere gesinnung
quasi rückschlüsse ziehen zu können das
empfinde ich als zutiefst unfair es gibt
in unserer rechtsordnung gibt es genug
regelungen die dafür sorgen dass bei
befangenheit sanktionen zu befürchten
sind ja auch weil richter innen und
dabei hätte man es belassen müssen für
ist diese grundsatzentscheidung des
bundesverfassungsgerichts bitter
denn sie und viele andere müssen sie
jetzt erst mal akzeptieren die
gesellschaftliche diskussion wie wir in
deutschland zusammen leben wollen die
steht aber gerade erst am anfang wie
seht ihr das wäre es für euch ein
problem werden eine richterin oder der
richter ein religiöses zeichen trägt
schreibt es doch gerne unten mal in die
kommentare
das bundesverfassungsgericht eigentlich
was ganz juristisches was ganz
abstraktes was mit unserem alltag kaum
was zu tun hat wenn ich mir aber die
fälle angucke und die einzelnen
entscheidungen dann hat das eine ganz
große auswirkungen auf unseren alltag
und auf das leben von uns allen schreibt
uns doch gerne mal die kommentare was
ihr über das gericht denkt und die
entscheidungen und lass uns ein leichter